hello and welcome to the agenda next
week Brussels to play host to a mini
plenary let's take a look at the
highlights along with the rest the hot
topics for the week ahead kicking things
off with something that we featured in
last week's agenda GMOs the vote to
allow member states to restrict or
prohibit their use will now go ahead at
a meeting of the Environment Committee
on Tuesday collecting passenger
information became ever more important
after nine eleven two thought global
acts of terrorism but legislation that
sought to get a European passenger name
record or PNR system up and running was
thrown out in april 2013 because it put
anybody and everybody under the
spotlight but now P&R is back on the
table and the reason to stop fighters of
the so-called Islamic state entering the
EU and committing acts of terrorism
follow the civil liberties committee
meeting on tuesday politics sometimes
overshadows the fact that EU is the
world's largest eight donor from
fighting Ebola in africa to funding
rural development programs in patan in
afghanistan the EU has projects all over
the world and with one purpose to
eradicate poverty the development
committee will discuss how to highlight
the european year for development on
tuesday
the images are etched in everyone's
memory the fall of the Berlin Wall was a
peaceful revolution that United east and
west pieces of the wall had been
scattered all over the globe like this
one outside the parliament as the many
plenary makes it returns the Brussels
chamber one of the top priorities will
be the 25th anniversary of the fall of
the Berlin Wall find out more details on
Wednesday
Franklin D Roosevelt was the first to
call for the respect of basic freedoms
that then formed the backdrop for the EU
zone founding principles the Four
Freedoms Goods workers capital and
services will be debated by any Peas on
Wednesday and that's all we have this
agenda take care and enjoy the week